well I'm on my way to the High Court and  just walking down Whitehall and I'm  walking past the very thing which is the  subject of the case which is being  concluded today in the high court and it  is what happened here at the gates of  Downing Street two years ago when Andrew  Mitchell tried to get through with his  bike did he get angry did he swear at  the police and ultimately did he call  them plebs that is the decision that the  judge has to make in this case the  summing up happens today it is a case  that has dramatically affected Andrew  Mitchell's career as it has the careers  of several police officers there is a su  a libel case against the Sun but there's  the counter libel case against mr.  Mitchell himself all will be decided  following this summing up and I'll be  keeping you updated on what's said  throughout the day and we'll get a  decision from the judge tomorrow